censure chaussée des écossais dans le
vieux québec et on est devant le monde
center aujourd'hui un centre culturel de
langue anglaise au début des années 1800
le moring center fut la toute première
prison municipale de la ville de québec
cette place tout juste devant l'entrée
servi à l'époque de lieu pour les
pendaisons pendant la ville à présent
stade et en 1867 il ya eu 16 pendaisons
publiques dont la moitié était pour fo
pour meur et un évidement et l'autre
pour les gens qui ont volé notamment du
thé en 1867 la prison ferme et des
ménages la vocation du lieu change s'y
installe en 1868 en même temps que la
bibliothèque de la houle est très riche
histoire
je me trouve assez chanceux d'avoir
l'occasion de travailler ici dans une
bibliothèque qui date plus de 150 ans
avec 27 mille livres
la société littéraire historique du
québec cherchait un endroit pour
bibliothèques et ils ont décidé de
déménager ça ici en même temps que le
collège s'y installent et lundi
conditions ans c'était que les élèves
auraient un accès gratuit à la
bibliothèque parce que ça coûtait dans
un temps ça coûtait très cher pour être
membres dans le texte et seulement les
élites qui avaient les moyens pour
devenir parts de la société
est-ce que tout est d'origine mais la
plupart de ce que vous voyez ici date de
l'ouverture de la bibliothèque
c'est à dire et à 1868 les bibliothèques
du maureen center est ouverte au public
plus besoin de faire partie de l'élite
mais simplement être membre pour la
modique somme de 20 $ par année
[Musique]